une ex ambassadrice qui en avait long à
dire devant les élus marie yovanovitch a
affirmé que c'est à la demande de dans
notre chambre lui même qu'elle a dû
quitter l'ukraine le printemps dernier
derrière des portes closes elle a
affirmé qu'à son retour aux états unis
son supérieur lui aurait indiqué que
bien qu'elle n'avait rien fait de mal
le président avait perdu confiance en
elle il ne souhaitait plus qu'elles
servent comme ambassadrice la diplomate
de carrière assure avoir été poussé vers
la sortie en raison d'allégations non
fondées de la part de gens aux
motivations questionnable une référence
entre autres à rudi giuliani l'avocat
personnel de dans notre chambre il a
accusé marie yovanovitch d'être biaisé
il se serait même plaint qu'elle nuisait
à ses efforts pour convaincre les
autorités ukrainiennes d'enquêter sur
dubaï donné son fils de partenaires de
monsieur giuliani aurait même fait
pression sur un élu américain pour que
l'ambassade ray soit relevé de ses
fonctions
ils ont été arrêtés hier pour avoir
violé les lois électorales des états
unis ce sénateur démocrate se dit
troublé par ces révélations qui semble
selon lui prouver l'existence d'un
réseau de diplomatie parallèle en
ukraine le président tschopp ne précise
pas pourquoi l'ancienne ambassadrice a
quitté son poste soulignant qu'elle est
peut-être une bonne personne
il laisse entendre que le nouveau
président ukrainien ne l'apprécié pas
nécessairement malgré la volonté du
président et son administration de ne
pas collaborer
l'anc est menée par les démocrates se
poursuit plusieurs autres diplomates y
compris l'ambassadeur américain auprès
de l'union européenne doivent
comparaître devant un congrès la semaine
prochaine ici rappelle gouvy auclair
radio-canada washington